that's brian flores talking about two of
tongobailoa knows where he needs to
improve
uh look i i
we have a hard time getting past what
happened last year
you get into a tough spot in a game
rookie quarterback
trying to get his feet wet trying to
learn the ropes trying to get some reps
trying to get to the point where the
game slows down and he gets yanked for
ryan
fitzpatrick now surely that's not going
to happen this year if it happens this
year chris
there's a problem yeah if jacoby
brissette comes into the games this year
as the relief pitcher for tuatanga byloa
there's a problem this is the year where
it's to a start to finish
every game barring injury and let's see
what he's got
yeah listen i mean i'm not giving up on
two i know i've been one of those that
you know wasn't the biggest fan of him
coming out in the draft and all those
things but there was still a lot of good
and hey listen like you're right we had
those concerns for a reason
but also those concerns you know arose
from
the fact that damn greer and flores just
they built a damn good team and it
turned it around in a hurry
i i mean i think that's part of it too
when you just take it in
in its context as a whole i mean yeah
ryan fitzpatrick that team kind of came
together
i think quicker than a lot of us thought
we thought hey miami was on the right
track but i don't think we
expected last year any of us to be
sitting there going
whoa miami's five and two and they look
like they're legit
you know that's that changed things and
of course then that put more pressure on
to it
so it wasn't the easiest situation i
think if we're going to be totally fair
to him
to kind of come into that and have to
take that over and have the pressure of
that
obviously he wasn't as nfl ready as ryan
fitzpatrick
but yeah i think too to add to that you
know and there's like the things to
to say hey that was tough for him but
the other aspect is yeah we need to see
more of them there's no doubt
there was lack of aggressive decisions
lack of aggressive throws
and you know inconsistency in moving the
ball especially through the air at times
and that's where we really want to see
him improve and
and take off as that franchise type guy
by the way it is 560 the joe wqam
brian flores was on the joe rose show i
finally got it right better never than
late anyway miles gaskin
running back on the miami dolphins here
he is talking about
the team's new approach on offense and
the key word
is new it's definitely different it's a
whole new playbook it's it's not the
same as last year's but it's not
i mean like i said it's still early
still picking it up so i mean i think
everybody's just very open-minded and
just kind of just
soaking it all in right now so
whole new playbook for a team that was
on the cusp of the playoffs last year
chris what what needs to change what
would you change about the dolphins
offense well i know i'm
interested to see where that's going to
go now is that going to be more like
rpo stuff that he kind of did in college
and was very successful there
at alabama that to me was the first
thing i thought of when i heard those
comments that maybe there's going to be
some more of that infused
into the game plan and everything like
that uh
now they got co-offensive coordinators i
mean they got george gottsie and
and studsville who are ones a run game
and pass game coordinator
so i don't know exactly what to expect
as far as the approach of their football
team
i can say this like they can build an
offense with the personnel they have
right now
to where it shouldn't feel like tua's
got to be the guy that's got to carry
the squad
i mean they got offensive lineman galore
in miami so they should be able to run
the ball
and be balanced that way but i would
think there's going to be more moving
parts with the fact that
hey to another gear in the nfl knowing
the system better
a guy like jalen waddle involved now
what he can bring to the table
you know and then just pushing to uh to
learn more
i would think that adds more wrinkles
and a little more depth to the playbook
and maybe that's what they're speaking
of there in miami
yeah you know it's it's hard to tell
until we start to see this is a team
that's trying to bust through
that you know brian flores i think has
been a great coach and i think he's got
the potential to become
one of the best coaches in football but
that they've got
to find a way to take the next step
last year it felt like they were going
to take it they just fell short of
qualifying for that 17
field in the afc and this year they got
to get over the top
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc
sports